[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello and welcome to the climate show
with me Tom Heap this week we focus our
lens on miracle cures for our energy
ills
mermaids tears littering our beaches and
moving photography of our environment
Under Siege how do they all stand up to
scrutiny
our civilization is pretty much powered
by burning stuff it's a sad Truth for
those fighting climate change but 80
percent of our energy still comes from
gas oil and coal sparking everything
from Cars to planes power stations to
central heating a fuel that delivered
that potency but lacked the pollution
would be a godsend there is one and it's
driving a new dash for gas hydrogen gas
the UK has a 240 million pound hydrogen
fund and the EU is promising eight and a
half billion pounds to Source this most
desirable molecule
hydrogen is the most abundant element in
the universe and in one form it falls
from the heavens and splashes on the
ground held in water as H2O
and that stream of tiny bubbles is pure
hydrogen on the other pencil there's a
little bit of oxygen coming off as well
and this is just by adding electricity
to water so in some ways making hydrogen
is pretty simple
away from the lab and closer to the
forecourt the same chemistry is
happening here here we have a hydrogen
electrolyzer that produces our green
hydrogen on-site and in here is the
process room we take tap water straight
from the mains and purify it using this
unit here it's making hydrogen to
deliver just over the wall to a filling
station you can refuel in a couple of
minutes get a range of over 300 miles
and all that's emitted is a little water
as the hydrogen and oxygen recombine
really nice car quick quiet and a decent
range but the problem for hydrogen cars
is the number of fueling stations only
around 11 public hydrogen points around
the country whereas for their competitor
for the future electric cars 50 000 plus
and also there's the opportunity to
charge them at home
so while private cars are turning to the
electric highway it's the big boys who
are hitching up to a hydrogen future
buses especially where cities are
driving down air pollution and
construction vehicles as Builders seek
to hit low-carbon targets
our business model for now is to go more
into trucks buses and fleets that return
to base because we can have one
refueling site hydrogen is also being
touted as a new jet fuel this week
Rolls-Royce trialed a hydrogen jet
engine albeit on the ground
and steel making also has its eye on the
H but these are both massive energy
users and hydrogen is bound by some
inconvenient facts of physics breaking
it from oxygen in water requires huge
amounts of energy which to be climate
friendly must come from low carbon
sources like wind or nuclear already
much in demand
it's also harder to handle than fuels we
know you can't carry it in a can the
tiny H2 molecule can leak out of
existing gas pipe work and it's
incredibly voluminous this tank can hold
just 32 kilos the weight of a large dog
enough to fuel up just 30 cars
one company has developed a cunning new
way of using hydrogen that doesn't need
a whole new fueling ecosystem and it can
even work on your classic old white van
Tom do you want to put the body up we'll
see what's under there well it looks
just the same as any other diesel engine
I've opened up well practically it is
and it does and it should the only
difference really with this is it has a
couple of extra components we've got a
plate type generator which generates a
hydrogen on demand in the engine and a
control box it's not a bit headline
terms what do you think this delivers
for us well it dramatically improves the
emissions of an existing Fleet of
vehicles so so you know the benefits are
there on the existing Vehicles rather
than having to replace and renew at huge
costs this technology is far from zero
carbon but fusion blue aren't the only
ones who believe the near future for
hydrogen is as an additive this lab is
working towards adding hydrogen to big
lorry engines with a one million pound
test engine with a special quartz glass
cylinder allowing researchers to analyze
how different mixes of fuel affect
combustion and reduce emissions we want
to use zero carbon fuel in existing
engine so that we can have a much faster
immediate carbon reduction for transport
sector so we need to look at the
hydrogen combustion process to help
improve the hydrogen engine efficiency
hydrogen may have a bright future but as
a regular fuel it's a long way off
so a brief Glimpse there of some
hydrogen tech let's hear now a couple of
competing visions of its potential
Panacea or bitpart player well to flesh
this out and really chew over where the
hydrogen is our kind of energy Savior
for the future I'm joined by Claire
Jackson Who's chief executive of
hydrogen UK the trade body representing
the business and also Michael librike
who runs his own business and advises on
clean energy there is some talk about
using hydrogen within heating for our
homes or the the businesses and
buildings behind us Michael does that
work for you well so there's 32
independent studies at this point that
looked at hydrogen versus
electrification heat pumps and District
Heating and a few other things not one
of them these are independent studies
not industry studies not one of them has
found a meaningful role for hydrogen in
heating but yeah the government is still
considering it for heating aren't they
well I think the government has is going
to decide believe in 2026 I think what
we've got is the government didn't want
to just turn around and tell this
massive industry that spending lots of
money lobbying that it's a simple flat
no so they haven't done that yet but
it's coming have you given up on
hydrogen for heating absolutely not heat
is one of the hardest areas that we have
to decarbonize and we need multiple
Solutions
um heat pumps are fantastic Technologies
but they're not suitable for every home
District heating is a fantastic
technology but it's not suitable for
every home and we need to make sure that
we have optionality so in some areas
heat pumps will be more cost effective
than hydrogen in other areas hydrogen
will be more cost effective than heat
pump give me an example where hydrogen
will work better for heating so for
example in a home where there's no space
for a heat pump where there's no space
for hot water storage
where there's particularly poor fabric
efficiency and it's very expensive to
upgrade hydrogen might be a better more
cost effective option than a heat pump
when it comes to making hydrogen
particularly green hydrogen it is
enormously energy hungry and if we're
talking about replacing a lot of
industrial uses of hydrogen which you
sort of have some agreement on between
you yeah we're talking massive amounts
of you know turbines or nuclear power
yeah yeah so we're going to need a lot
of hygiene which is going to need a lot
of Renewables we also have other ways of
producing hydrogen by capturing carbon
from natural gas so we have multiple
sources of making hydrogen but the other
important thing is when we look at this
from an energy system perspective
um you know we use an awful lot of
energy in Winter and not so much in
summer and hydrogen is a really good
option for balancing that system so
you'd store it in the summer and use it
yeah the other the other aspect is that
we move probably about you know two
three times more energy through our
pipes than we do our pylons and if we're
going to try and Electrify a decent
chunk of Transport try to Electrify the
entire heat as well for absolutely
insane pressure on our electricity
system so utilizing hydrogen alongside
heat pumps will result in a more
affordable and resilient Energy System
but it's pretty difficult to put
hydrogen through the existing gas
structure isn't it it's such a tiny
molecule leaks out it's actually not
there are studies that have been done to
date show that actually it's perfectly
feasible and technically feasible and
economically feasible to run hydrogen
through the pipes that we have today and
that's because we've gone through a
process of changing out our metal pipes
for plastic pipes when you combine these
these things the The energy needed to
make it and also there is some
complexities you say in handling it do
you think it works at a large scale
solution when do you think these things
are credible oh definitely look it's an
industrial gas and it can be handled
it's handled all over the place in the
world already industrially the issue is
really you don't want hydrogen in the
homes it is being portrayed as what does
it keep the keep the boiler change the
gas but you've got to change the boiler
the hob the oven any heaters that you
might have and it is a difficult to
handle industrial gas it also produces
nitrous oxides when you burn it so this
is just something we don't want to do
for all sorts of reasons just a very
quick one on aircraft if I may it's
being suggested as a potential fuel
there but it is incredibly bulky and we
saw a tank that was almost the size of
of a tank on the back of a conventional
tanker which held 32 kilograms of
hydrogen you know it doesn't seem
plausible for aircraft um so an aircraft
will probably be using liquid hydrogen
rather than sort of Compressed Gas
hydrogen which means that the volume
required is much smaller it's still more
than the conventional jet fuel today but
it is um it's a very heavy thing to
contain it as liquid yeah for sure but
it's still there's very few options that
we have for jet fuel and hydrogen is a
really good option that's being explored
by Airbus by EasyJet by Rolls-Royce and
the jet engines it's a really promising
technology in that area briefly
plausible for flight absolutely not
um short haul airplane one third of it
taken up by liquid hydrogen but the
really the fun one we need system
thinking here right liquid hydrogen how
do you get it to Heathrow you're not
putting it in a pipe at minus 253
Centigrade right so what are you going
to do you're going to bring it by 3
000 liquid hydrogen tanker trucks per
day or are you going to liquefy it in
Heathrow with the sort of electricity
demand that is produced by a whole big
nuclear power station and and I mean
it's just not been thought through in
the end we're talking about such a big
scale thing as we said 80 of our energy
is dependent on fossil fuels that you'd
both agree replacing that with hydrogen
is just an epic task I mean I don't
think that anyone is suggesting that
we're going to replace 80 of our fossil
fuels by with with hydrogen but hydrogen
will have a key role to play alongside
electrification these two things need to
work together to deliver Net Zero so
what's being suggested is about 20 of
the Energy System replaced by hydrogen
the right answer is probably about two
percent okay that there's a difference
the Michael Lee Frank and Claire Jackson
thank you very much now from one source
of clean energy to another and it's time
to answer one of the many questions
you've been sending in on the Sky News
app William asked why can we not have
solar panels on every Council house and
private houses too if they agree the
incentive would be much more free
electricity well the issue here is that
they may generate electricity for free
when the sun shines but they're not free
to install the energy saving trust
reckons they cost about five and a half
thousand pounds for a typical domestic
rig that would put out around three and
a half kilowatt hours maximum that's
when you've got a lot of sun during the
summer now that amount of energy is
enough to run most of the electrics in a
typical home but of course we don't all
live in the summer all year round there
are times when the clouds come over or
indeed it's winter so it doesn't
generate for you all the time so you
still need electricity from the grid it
certainly helps in terms of your bills
and in terms of climate but it's finding
that money up front which is the key
both for individuals and if you want
this as a national policy for the
government too
well when you think plastic pollution
bottles or bags probably spring to mind
less known but potentially worse are
these nerdles they're tiny pellets used
in plastic manufacture every year more
than 50 billion of them are thought to
enter UK Waters and now a global nerdle
hunt has found them on almost every
Beach Skye Aisha zahid reports on what
are known as mermaids tears
while scouring this beach in Lime Kiln
it doesn't take very long to find
nerdles
they're tiny pellets of plastic used by
manufacturers
but spills during handling and
transportation mean instead of ending up
in our Plastic Products too often
they're washing up on shore
over on this beach and we're standing on
what we're dealing with is historical
nerd or loss and I would say that lots
of noodles here have been here decades
and they're washing up maybe being
dragged up from the bottom of the first
or fourth and deposited or they're just
sitting in the bank if you can look at
this
pot of noodles this isn't even a
collection of noodles of people picking
them up with tweezers this is handfuls
of just the beach being picked up so we
want to ask why is no one accountable
for this pollution on our beach that
we're having to live with every day
children are playing amongst it Wildlife
is ingesting it
where responsibility lies isn't clear
and that's because there's no regulation
on how nerdal spills are managed despite
their environmental impact as well as
just looking not very nice on a beach
and smothering beaches in plastic
unfortunately a lot of noodles are
mistaken for food by a lot of marine
animals animals such as sea birds fish
dolphins and baby turtles as well as
this noodles can carry toxic pollutants
on their surface transporting nasty
chemicals around the world as well
the problem continues to grow this
year's great Global nerd or hunt held by
the environmental charity fedra found
more of the plastic pellets on beaches
around the world than ever before
hunts took place at 317 sites in 23
countries and nirdles were found in 90
of these locations the only country
where no plastic pellets were found was
Indonesia but could we see these numbers
improve in the future
environmentalists are hopeful if
legislation is brought in we need to see
noodles classified formally as Marine
pollutants so that their packaged most
stringently they're labeled more clearly
and the presence of pellets on ships is
communicated to The Operators so they
can be stowed below deck and in more
safe and appropriate manner
they may be small but there's no doubt
that these nerdles pose huge problems
once they're in the environment they're
incredibly difficult to clean up so
Focus needs to be on preventing them
from getting there in the first place
Aisha zahid Sky News
now here on the show we're always Keen
to keep an eye on the amount of energy
that's coming from Renewables as it
gradually increases across the world and
here in the UK well let's have a look at
this week you can see wind here
generated around a quarter of the energy
in the last week of the electricity
technically I should say and it also
seems that wind is enjoying a bit more
of favor within Politics as well with
the business and Energy Secretary
insisting that wind projects could be
built onshore if there was support from
the local community well a poll
commissioned by Renewables UK suggests
that that might not be as much of a
problem as Folk think it found that 76
percent of people support building
renewable energy projects in their local
area and that number actually Rises to
81 among people who voted conservative
in 2019
there are now an increasing number of
projects where local residents can buy
part of their own wind turbine and these
are known as Community wind farms
the community energy wind farms our wind
farms are owned by communities now they
can be Geographic communities but in
Ripple's case we enable people from all
across Great Britain to come together
and collectively own wind farms
[Music]
it's allowing the community to get
involved in safety environments
foreign
with energy that the project the wind
farm or the solar Park is located where
the resource is better that's probably
not going to be in the middle of a city
like this but we think that even if you
live in a city or a town you should
still be able to own your own sorts of
clean power
all these people around me they probably
don't live near anywhere that's suitable
to put a wind farm up or or a sailor
pass so we enable everyone no matter
where in the country they live to own
their own part of a wind farm and get it
supplied to them by the grid
foreign
amendments to the energy bill to empower
communities energy schemes to sell their
power directly to local companies and
customers
the gentleman makes a very good point
and I know my right humble friend would
be very happy to take that conversation
forward
often the most powerful messages about
climate and environment can be conveyed
in a single frame One Moment In Time
captured by a camera the environmental
photographer of the Year Awards have
just been announced and here to talk us
through some of the winners is the
competitions founder Terry Fuller Terry
tell us why did you set this up
we want to tell the most important
stories that we're ever going to tell
about our planet and doing that through
imagery is a really powerful way of
appealing to people's hearts and invoke
action well we're going to have a look
through some of your top award winners
in a moment we're going to start with
the one that was the youth Award winner
which was some flamingos here we've
actually managed to get a little
interview with the man who took the shot
fiz Khan
just being nominated alone was
um
it was an absolute honor and to actually
win the award from people who care so
deeply about our environment it's just
like it's more than a dream come true I
would hope to use my photography as a
tool to help people to think
respectfully about our environment and
try to make a change and I think these
images not only taken by me of course by
all the other intestines is a very good
way of inspiring people and helping them
think respectfully about our planet
fires can't there well Terry let's have
a little look around our virtual virtual
Gallery here starting with with a couple
over here incredible image at the top
this one of nature kind of taking over
yes it is fascinating
um I mean we see two sides of the coin
when it comes to Nature NH recovery
um we see the fragility of Nature and um
in against the impacts of climate change
but also the resilience and the ability
to recover and this illustrates that I
think quite nicely there's a kind of
sci-fi movie feeling about the top one
that I have to say it appeals to me the
bottom one a lot more destructive but
really powerful as an image it is really
powerful and particularly when you get
to the story behind it I mean tragically
49 people lost their lives in that
explosion that's portrayed in the image
there but in addition to that the
explosion caused huge amount of
disruption in terms of pollution as well
yeah well let's have a look at some
images over here some of these are a
little bit more kind of futuristic if
you like
um we we've got this one of of the sort
of future of of Agriculture maybe this
vertical Farm yeah it's particularly
exciting because we've tried to nudge
the competition over the years towards
showing us the hope and the solutions to
climate challenges and building climate
resilience and this this certainly
illustrates that and I particularly like
it because we know as a global
population we're going to move more into
urban environments and City living and
this gives us the opportunity to
actually produce food in those types of
environments not necessarily out in the
rural landscape and this this bottom one
I love it's that kind of fashion for
Cold Water swimming and getting in the
environment but also of course wind
turbines low carbon solution in the
background indeed yes and of course wind
turbines are nothing new but what we
liked about this image is that these um
this wind farm was produced out of a
Cooperative with the local community so
there's a real connection there and
people have bought into that great well
let's have a look at the big winner now
if you take a step back over there we
can we can have a look at it in our in
our Central image here
um a flamingo but rather a rather a sad
story what is the uh the narrative
behind this well this picture is taken
in um a nature reserve in Iran and it's
a particularly important International
important Reserve teaming with wildlife
and and Rich ecology the story here is
though that through Land Management
practices and reduction in water
available in this Wetland these birds
have died through inhaling and consuming
toxic materials it's such a
juxtaposition isn't it because we think
of flamingos as one of the ultimately
sort of beautiful and slightly fragile
slightly otherworldly almost and here
well they're suffering because of our
world and what we're doing to it well
indeed it's a majestic creature and it's
been reduced to that and I think it's
that alone makes us wonder about our
place in the world and what we're doing
to the natural world around us well
Terry thank you very much indeed that's
great and I'm sure the viewers can look
at this by looking for the environmental
photographer of the year thanks so much
for your time well this week's climate
cast has more on the pros and cons of
hydrogen power that we were looking at
earlier you can download it from
wherever you get your podcasts or if you
scan the QR code on the screen right now
you can listen to the latest episode
well that's it for the climate show this
week don't forget we'll bring you the
latest every weekday at half past three
here on Sky News but for now goodbye
[Music]